The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
[HYDRAULICS HISSING]
[MACHINE RUMBLING]
EARLL MURMAN: Well,
good morning, Claudio.
CLAUDIO GELMAN:
Good morning, Earll.
Thank you, again, for coming.
It's always a pleasure to
show you the factory to you.
So before the main
purpose of today,
I'll show you the value stream,
the factory, the product flow.
But before that, I'm
going to give you
a little preview of who we are.
EARLL MURMAN: Oh, wonderful.
Yeah.
Well, everybody
knows New Balance,
but tell us about
your journey to lean.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Specifically
about the Lawrence factory.
The factory, it specifically
is divided into--
standing here, you've got to
your left side the portion
that we call the
[? cutting ?] stage.
This is the made in America
shoes that we cut from scratch
and we cut here.
And to your right--
it's my right side--
is what we call the
source upper world.
We get the sole and
the upper from Asia,
and we just put it together.
EARLL MURMAN: Now, are
you the only shoe company
that actually manufactures
shoes in the US?
CLAUDIO GELMAN: I
understand yes, it is.
EARLL MURMAN: That's
what's behind me here.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: And that's our
competitive advantage is great.
You know, turn around
shoes in two or three days.
EARLL MURMAN: Two or three days?
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Yeah,
we're going to get it
in the customer's hand.
EARLL MURMAN: We'll see
how you do that when
we go through the value stream.
CLAUDIO GELMAN:
Absolutely, I'll show that.
So some statistics, we
pack 5,200 pair a day
and ship 5,200 pair a day.
We are 220 associates.
I'm going to show you when we go
through operation and the value
stream, which is a group
operation put strategically
in a cell or U-shape
to make a product.
There's some history behind
it, and it's very interesting.
What you see here is a
product of three and a half,
four years of lean
transformation.
Three and a half
years ago, we decided
to work with a
[INAUDIBLE] production
company to learn about that,
their production system,
which lean is
another name for it.
Four years ago,
it used to take us
eight days to make
a pair of shoes.
Eight days.
EARLL MURMAN: From
start to finish?
CLAUDIO GELMAN: From
start to finish.
EARLL MURMAN: You mean you
weren't working on that shoe
the whole time but
start to finish--
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Well,
that's a good question
because it's what we call
the value added work,
which was only 23 minutes.
So the shoe was floating in
this factory for eight days,
with only associates
touching the shoe,
adding value to the
shoe for 23 minutes.
With lean transformation,
after three and a half years,
we went from eight
days to right now,
it would take us between two
and three hours in value stream
to produce a pair of shoes.
So that's in 98% reduction.
EARLL MURMAN: It's still about
23 minutes of value added time?
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Yes, absolutely.
EARLL MURMAN: So
there's actually still
some room potentially
for improvement.
CLAUDIO GELMAN:
Once you start lean,
it becomes part of your DNA.
You never stop.
Well, you see supervisors
and flow coordinators,
which are our team leaders,
always with a watch,
looking at the cycle
time to see if there's
opportunity to improve.
So there are other
statistics we reduced.
We used to be in two floors.
Right now, we're in one.
We emptied a quarter.
I think it's close to
2,500 square feet of floor.
The beginning of
a value stream--
in those days, it was
not called value stream.
It was like straight lines--
used to be in the first
floor, the beginning.
And being on the second floor
was too much communication.
EARLL MURMAN: So now you can
see the whole value stream.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: And
I'll show you later,
from a management
point of view, they
built it to have a value stream
where the beginning and the end
meet.
It's extremely powerful.
So square footage, I think,
is close to 30% reduction.
It's a work in process.
Like I said, 98%,
so it's incredible.
So how did we do that?
Part of lean, there are two
basic concepts, takt time,
which is flow based on our
capacity of the value stream
and availability.
It's a takt time of 25,
22 and 1/2 seconds, which
means that it's a frequency.
Takt time is a
frequency of delivery,
so at the end of
the line, you will
see a shoe leaving every 22.
EARLL MURMAN: Or a
pair of shoes every 45.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Absolutely.
So that's the concept of
the takt time and flow,
and the other
concept is of waste.
Actually, we have a course we
call waste detectives, where
we put our associates
through and identify,
what is a way in
the lean world--
EARLL MURMAN: Is every
associate a waste detective?
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Yes,
that's where they are.
Everyone here becomes
a waste detective.
I have a poster,
very interesting,
that I like to use for tours and
also for educational purposes,
where in the lean world, they
are like the deadly wastes.
And they are-- I'll go through
with you-- overproduction,
when we produce ahead, waiting,
and this is very interesting.
There are some
interesting pictures,
with associates participating
in them, of the examples.
Transportation, overprocessing.
EARLL MURMAN: So just on
the waiting, for example,
eight days with 23
minutes of value
added, there was
a lot of waiting.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Yes, and
it used to be normal.
Now, it's--
EARLL MURMAN: On transportation,
you had two floors before.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Absolutely.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN:
Overprocessing, this
is a interesting way that people
sometimes have to understand.
In this particular
case, this shoe,
it needs a row of
stitching at the bottom.
Now, they put two.
People may think, well,
two is better than one.
No, it's not.
The shoe needs one, but
sometimes, we tend to add two.
Like maybe three coats of
paint when two was enough.
EARLL MURMAN: Oh,
very interesting.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: So
we look into that.
EARLL MURMAN: Yeah.
CLAUDIO GELMAN:
Excess inventory.
EARLL MURMAN: Yep.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Waste.
I mean, interesting,
assets seems
to be in the balance sheets.
EARLL MURMAN: And
we'll see this--
CLAUDIO GELMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
EARLL MURMAN: We'll
see this as soon as we
start the value stream walk.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Absolutely.
Actually, this is the first
part of the cutting department.
Unnecessary motion, safety
has a lot to do with here.
Here, you have an
associate placing a shoe
and overstretching, very
different from getting closer
to an associate.
And defects.
And we added an eight, which
is unused associate creativity.
EARLL MURMAN: Wonderful.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: It's wonderful.
What we've all been trained here
is that, as we walk the floor,
we do analysis.
We are trying to
identify this waste.
We see somebody overstretching.
It's motion.
We see somebody waiting.
So whenever we
see this waste, we
put together a continuous
improvement activity.
They call this an activity.
So the whole goal is
reduce waste, improve flow.
Reduce waste, improve flow.
EARLL MURMAN: I want to
see your value stream.
Can we get started?
CLAUDIO GELMAN:
Let's start it, then.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Absolutely.
EARLL MURMAN: Wonderful.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: This is the
beginning of the value stream.
EARLL MURMAN: So this is the
front end of your value stream
here?
CLAUDIO GELMAN: This is the
front end of our value stream.
EARLL MURMAN: And you don't
call this a department.
You call it a value stream.
CLAUDIO GELMAN:
The value stream.
The definition is the
value stream is a series
of operations put in
sequence-- we call it a cell--
to make a particular product.
It doesn't have
to be one product.
It can two products,
three products,
but there is some
similar operations.
And then you can connect them.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
Now in a little
bit bigger sense,
your value stream goes all
the way back to your suppliers
and eventually out to
your stores and so on,
but we're looking just
at the value stream--
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Absolutely.
EARLL MURMAN:
--starting with what's
coming from the suppliers.
And maybe at the
end, we'll see what's
going out to your stores.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Correct.
And as a concept of
value stream issues
within a cell in manufacturing,
the [? concept ?]
is also true for the
whole corporation,
whether we are, let's say,
a purchasing department.
It would be a department part
of the whole corporation's value
stream, so you are correct.
EARLL MURMAN: Yeah.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: So what you
see here is the cutting.
That's the first operation,
and basically, materials
are coming from our suppliers.
They come in in rolls.
They go to the
consolidation center
and then pull based on the
demand and the production
schedule.
EARLL MURMAN: So
this value stream
pulls based on its demand.
CLAUDIO GELMAN:
Exactly, exactly.
And the materials
are layered, and we
build what we call a web.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
I can see it's stapled.
It's stapled right there.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Exactly.
How much is a given to
the cutter its based--
so we have a
computer system that,
based on the schedule,
the number of pairs,
the size, and the width, puts
out how many pairs we need
and then how much square
footage to give to the cutter.
EARLL MURMAN: How frequently
you make that calculation?
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Well,
it's per quarter.
Like, daily.
EARLL MURMAN: Daily?
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Daily.
Daily, and right now with the
different materials, almost
any calculation, we deliver
45 hours worth of material.
EARLL MURMAN: So that's
kind of like adjusting time.
CLAUDIO GELMAN:
Absolutely, absolutely.
So the cutter will
pick up what's
called a die, which has
the shape of the part,
with the hydraulic machine and
place the die on the material.
The placement of the
die is called nesting.
EARLL MURMAN: Nesting.
OK.
You're trying to
minimize waste, I guess.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Exactly,
it's like a puzzle.
Cutters may take from
three months to six months
to get good at it, not only to
understand where the die goes,
but also make it with speed
because talk about speed.
Let me talk a bit of
a key concept, which
is the concept of takt time.
In the lean world, the goal is
to flow and to reduce waste,
flow and to reduce waste.
Based on the demand
in this value stream,
which is 50 cases a day,
a case being 12 pairs,
and available time per day--
EARLL MURMAN: That's
600 pairs a day
that this value stream puts out?
CLAUDIO GELMAN:
[INAUDIBLE] specifically.
And seven and a half
hours in a shift.
The frequency of output is
22 and 1/2 seconds per shoe.
That frequency is
called takt time.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Takt time.
Now, although I just mentioned
that the frequency is
22 and 1/2 seconds per
shoe, at this stage,
because of the characteristics
of the operation,
we are not flowing
one shoe at a time.
We are still in a batch world.
EARLL MURMAN: OK,
but a small batch?
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Small batches.
In the past, as I said before,
when our lead time was eight
days, in an equivalent
value stream,
we will have close to
400 cases of [INAUDIBLE]..
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Now, with
the lead time of three hours,
our work in process
is 20, 25 cases.
That's a reduction of 98%.
EARLL MURMAN: So I see a little
green thing on the floor,
and the visual control says
cutting whip, seven cases
maximum.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Absolutely.
EARLL MURMAN: So that's
all the space you've got.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: So the cutters
will cut the individual parts
based on the material,
and they will be
placing the parts on the bins.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: When
they finish the hour--
so here, the unit of flow--
you can call it an hour--
could be between six and seven
cases, depending on the style.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
So while we're here, I see
a broom hanging up there,
so I want to just
ask you about 5S.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: 5S,
actually, it's very typical.
5S is a system or
an organization.
5S is for Sort, Sitting
Order, Shine, Standardize,
and Sustain.
And it's much more
than just cleaning.
Once you understand the 5S,
there are economics in place,
and there is a very
key location of parts.
This is the first system
implemented five years ago.
EARLL MURMAN: I was
going to ask you.
It's hard for me almost
to imagine a place
where it wouldn't
naturally be 5S,
but you had to start with 5S.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Exactly, because
one of, I think, the mistakes
is thinking that 5S
is just cleaning.
So everybody
understands cleaning,
and there's so much to clean.
And when you're
starting a new process,
you can get so many
gains by just cleaning.
It looks good, but
there's much more to it.
But the broom in that place
with the label that says broom,
that's been--
EARLL MURMAN: It becomes part
of your organizing your self.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Absolutely,
and it goes deeper.
I think that 5S is actually
a reflection of leadership.
If you cannot get an
organized workplace and clean,
your chances of flowing product
and meeting that takt time are
very slim, so it has to
do with the discipline.
It's much deeper than
that, than just cleaning.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: So this
is a cutting department.
About seven cases
now, and we're going
to walk to the next department
is called the prefit department
part of the value stream.
EARLL MURMAN: It looks like
the second part of the value
stream.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: It's the second
thing in the value stream.
EARLL MURMAN: You
got the cutting.
Now we're going to do stitches.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Exactly.
The prefit is a
shoe-making technique.
Many years ago when we
didn't have computers,
the way a shoe was stitched
is it used to be fitted,
two parts coming together,
and a very skillful stitcher
would put it together.
Before you're able to prefit
and stitch it, we fit it.
It needs to be prefitted,
which is you do marking.
You do embroidery.
You do other things before
you put the shoe together.
That's where the name
comes from, prefit.
So we do embroidery
with the logo.
EARLL MURMAN: That's
where the NB comes on.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Our
main USA logo is there.
And then you will see a series
of miscellaneous operations
that are required to
make a shoe, for example,
the reinforcement of the tip.
I talked about embroidery.
Some styles take embroidery.
Others do not.
Here, we have a machine called
[INAUDIBLE],, a radio frequency
machine.
It's not being operated
right now, but as an example,
this is the part that will
make these [? decals. ?]
It's a nice feature because
it's nice what it's going to do.
Again, some cells have it.
Some cells do not.
And if he go through
the team, you'll
see associates making other
miscellaneous operations
to the parts of the shoe.
EARLL MURMAN: You have the flow
of material start over there,
goes to the--
CLAUDIO GELMAN: So we
go cutting, prefit.
Well, let's go to the
computer stitching,
and we'll see some stitching and
then eventually the assembly,
where they put the sole on.
EARLL MURMAN: So if things
are getting a little out
of sequence, timing-wise,
could someone from here
go over and help
the prefit people?
CLAUDIO GELMAN: It's
a very good point.
When we changed from the
batch and queue world
to the lean world, we changed
the management system.
In the past, you have
associates and supervisors,
nobody in the middle.
In order to support that takt
time of 22 and 1/2 seconds
and maintain that flow,
now we changed the system
where we have the
supervisors, we
have the team leaders,
and then the associates.
So team leaders fill in if there
is a disruption of any kind,
a bathroom break to a phone
call to a quality issue.
They will jump in to
maintain the flow.
EARLL MURMAN: The
team leader will?
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Absolutely.
EARLL MURMAN: So the team
leader can do everything?
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Absolutely, yes.
So still, in this team and
the prefit, we have batches.
The parts are prefitted.
We put a reinforcement
to the toe
and make a little [INAUDIBLE].
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: These
associates, they
are making little
holes on the part.
They put them back on those
bins that we talked before
and brought [INAUDIBLE] batch
to this department that's
called computer stitching.
EARLL MURMAN:
Computer stitching.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: So what I'm
going to show you right now
are stitching machines, but they
have a computer and cameras.
And the way it works, you'll
see an associate picking
these kinds of parts,
put them on what's
called a pallet, these little
holes that you put on pins.
And they probably will
be fed into this machine,
and you have lights taking
pictures and a computer.
And it's taking a picture
three frames per second,
so the cameras tell the
computer, this is the edge.
And the computer tells
the sewing machine
where to put the stitch.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: At this
computer stitching department
is where we transition
from the batch to the flow,
and that's what I'm
going to show you now.
EARLL MURMAN: OK, great.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: This
associate here--
I forgot to mention
when we talked
about the different management
system, remember takt time
and flow.
Supervisor and team
leader to help,
but also, we want associates
to be on the line producing
the shoes at that takt time.
So another level is
called the point of use.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: The
goal of point of use
is to bring the parts to--
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: --the
operators, actually adding value
to the shoe.
EARLL MURMAN: So this lady's
a point of use associate?
CLAUDIO GELMAN: That's correct,
a point of use associate.
EARLL MURMAN: She
looks pretty busy, too.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Very busy.
They have to distribute a
case every nine minutes,
and they have the flow from
this computer stitching
to the next department
and come back and flow.
Everything is about flow.
EARLL MURMAN: So
you want to keep
this person-- you want to
have everything she needs
to do what she needs to do.
CLAUDIO GELMAN:
Exactly, exactly.
In the past world, this person
would leave the machine,
would go and pick up
the parts, come back.
A lot of variability in the
system, and reduction of waste
is to reduce variability
at the same time.
EARLL MURMAN: They must have
to work very closely together.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Yes, absolutely.
So here, you have the
computer stitching machine.
These are the parts that
came from the cutting,
and the associate puts
the parts on this pallet.
It's fed into the machine.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
Goes back in the machine.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: You got the
cameras taking pictures.
EARLL MURMAN: And
now it's stitching.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: And then
the sewing machine's
stitching where the computers
tell them to stitch.
The pallet comes up.
Here, we got the part.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Now,
why only three parts?
It's because under the takt time
of 22 and 1/2 seconds, that's
all that fits in this machine.
So we take all the time that
is required to stitch a shoe.
We divide it by 22
and 1/2 seconds,
and that tells us
how many associates
we need to put to flow.
EARLL MURMAN: Now, when you
switched to the takt time
approach, did you have to
redesign some of these machines
to--
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Completely.
In the past--
EARLL MURMAN: The old machines
couldn't fit the takt time?
CLAUDIO GELMAN: I'm sorry.
The machines are OK.
We have to change the
thinking of the designing
of the pallets.
In the past in the
batch and queue world,
we were very proud when we could
put as many layers as possible
to save machinery.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: The goal
was the machine efficiency.
EARLL MURMAN: Great.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Because
you get rewarded in a batch
world for machine efficiency.
Right now, the goal
is into efficiency
and associate [? tool ?] safety.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: So
what we did is now
we don't takt as many
layers as we can.
We only put enough
layers to maintain flow.
The machines are the
same, but the design
of the pallet and the number
of parts has changed radically.
EARLL MURMAN: Very good.
And did the associates
participate in that redesign?
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Oh, absolutely.
I mean, that's a great question.
When we talk about
the team leaders,
that's one of the
major, major changes.
You know, we're reading the
books about our associates
are [INAUDIBLE] assets.
And I think we're
talking about--
you know, we're doing
great things here,
where associates
have a great part
in the problem-solving activity
and the design, supervisors
and team leaders
consulting all the time.
That's what makes a
big, big difference.
But before when we
talk about batch,
now you see single
[INAUDIBLE] flow.
You have flow.
EARLL MURMAN: So
we've got a cell here.
We have a cell.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: You
have a cell, exactly.
EARLL MURMAN: I mean, this is a
very good graphical realization
of a cell.
You can see it all
connected together.
CLAUDIO GELMAN:
That's a good point.
This is a good
example of flowing,
and we ask them not to
have more than two pairs.
EARLL MURMAN: It says right
there, two pairs only.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Two
pairs only, yes.
EARLL MURMAN: And you got some
visual work instructions here.
CLAUDIO GELMAN:
Absolutely, that's
part of the standardized
work, where we
define the standardized width.
And visual management
is a big part of it,
and if you have more, if I
see three pairs, you know,
there's a problem because
the associate probably
was having a problem.
The flow coordinator,
or the-- we
call the flow coordinator
the team leaders.
We calling them
flow coordinators.
EARLL MURMAN: Oh, they're
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Yeah, it's
the name we came up with.
EARLL MURMAN: That's much
better than team leader,
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Yeah,
because their goal is
to maintain the flow, in a way.
EARLL MURMAN: Well, the
title flow coordinator
means-- a team leader
focuses on them.
The flow coordinator focuses
on what they're doing.
CLAUDIO GELMAN:
Exactly, exactly.
So visually, if you
see three pairs,
the flow coordinator
will come and say,
something is not right.
So visually, very powerful.
EARLL MURMAN: So Claudio, I
see some little red dots here
where it says, red color label.
What are those for?
CLAUDIO GELMAN: It could be
that these machines sometimes
are very sensitive to
the shape of the part.
Because you're taking a picture,
the part is sort of warped.
It fools the machine, so
in shoe-making technology,
it can have a stitch runoff.
So they're searching
for a little red dot,
and as it goes by,
the flow coordinator
will notice, fix it quickly,
and put it back into the line.
EARLL MURMAN: Now, is that
something that came out
of an employee suggestion?
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Probably, yeah.
And they like to have that, and
they identify it themselves.
At least, the defect is there,
but they take ownership.
That's a big thing that changed.
In the past, they
were just trying to,
you know-- we have inspectors
on the line put in the dots.
Now, defects happen, but
now they have ownership.
And we're very proud.
It's really an environment that
it's OK to show their mistakes,
and there's no problem.
EARLL MURMAN: And
they're happy with that?
CLAUDIO GELMAN:
Oh, not a problem.
And interestingly, when
we changed from the batch
to the lean, standards
are very important.
Standardized work, which is
the definition of the best
flow of a product, considering
cost, [INAUDIBLE],, economics.
And some people
thought, well, if I
have to do always
the same, management
was concerned that
our associates
would feel like robots.
And the feedback that we
got after a few months
of lean implementation
is that they
love to know what
they have to do,
so management and even
human resource's concept
that they would feel like
robots was not correct.
And what we're trying to
teach them is that instead
of a paradox-- because
standardized work tells
you, always have to
do the same thing,
but as you do always
the same thing,
you have a foundation
for problem-solving
and for continuous improvement.
So standardized work is a
continuous improvement tool.
It depends how you
look at things.
Through that repetition,
they will recommend changes.
EARLL MURMAN: That's a
really interesting approach
because that makes standardized
work be something where you're
always trying to
improve it compared to,
now we can forget about it.
CLAUDIO GELMAN:
Right, absolutely.
But that's another thing.
Sometimes, we go crazy,
and it never stops.
Once you've got
the stream rewired
for continuous improvement,
it never stops.
Because of management, it
really changed radically.
Managers become more
teachers and coaches.
Challenges, I
think, it's always--
production managers,
we call them,
they always have to
have gentle tension.
In my experience of what I read,
you will not introduce lean
with that tension.
You know, I read somewhere else.
This is like a pressure cooker.
It's always pressure to
just release the pressure.
EARLL MURMAN: Very
good analysis.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: OK.
EARLL MURMAN: Great.
Maybe we should move on.
CLAUDIO GELMAN:
Yes, so here, you
got the case ready for
the next department.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN:
And the case will
be sent to the
stitching department,
so I think we should go around.
And I'll show you
from the beginning.
EARLL MURMAN: OK, very good.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: We're
just going to go around.
EARLL MURMAN: OK, good.
Boy, a lot of
visual control here.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Yes, so I
wanted to talk to you about that
before we talk about
the stitching cell.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Takt time, flow.
Flow coordinators are
required to keep details of--
you have the exact idea
of the plan versus actual,
if there are any deviations.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: This
is the production board
for the last team that
we haven't talked yet,
but if there is negative,
they have to put a reason.
In this case, it was
waiting for the closing.
Closing happened to be--
EARLL MURMAN: This is today's?
CLAUDIO GELMAN: This is today.
EARLL MURMAN: So I
have five after 8:00,
and this says 7:00 to 8 o'clock.
So immediately,
this was filled in.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Yes.
EARLL MURMAN: Because we're
now on this shift here.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Right, and
we'll see what happened.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: OK?
Yeah, that's a good observation.
So for supervisors,
managers, you come here,
and you know we're
waiting for closing.
So the first
question I will have,
what happened in closing
and the stitching?
You have a board there that
then the flow coordinator says,
machine number seven
was down for 10 minutes.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Just
big picture detail.
On their desk, they
have a more detailed log
that will tell
them what happened
with that particular
machine, but you
see how they're connected.
EARLL MURMAN: Very, very good.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: And it's part
of the supervisor and management
to make sure that
they make sense.
EARLL MURMAN: Morning.
ROSE MARY MUNOZ: [INAUDIBLE]
broken the thread.
Good morning.
How are you?
EARLL MURMAN: Good.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: You see?
They've broken the thread.
ROSE MARY MUNOZ:
Broken the thread.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: That's why--
EARLL MURMAN: Oh,
the thread broke?
CLAUDIO GELMAN:
The thread broke.
That's what we're talking about.
She knows about it.
ROSE MARY MUNOZ: I
told [INAUDIBLE]..
CLAUDIO GELMAN: OK.
EARLL MURMAN: Is she
the flow coordinator?
CLAUDIO GELMAN:
She's a supervisor,
25 years in the company.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: What an asset.
ROSE MARY MUNOZ: That's my team.
EARLL MURMAN: Yeah,
so this her team.
ROSE MARY MUNOZ: Uh-huh.
EARLL MURMAN: I saw
you're way up there.
[LAUGHTER]
CLAUDIO GELMAN: So like
we were talking before,
we talked about the [INAUDIBLE]
generation, problem-solving,
involvement, and we
have a very simple way
to appreciate the associates.
To talk about interaction
between supervisor
and associates, I will introduce
to you Rose Mary Munoz.
She's our supervisor--
EARLL MURMAN: Buenos dias.
ROSE MARY MUNOZ: Buenos dias.
Como estas?
CLAUDIO GELMAN: --in
the wide value stream.
She's been with a
company 25 years.
EARLL MURMAN: Wow.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: So
she's seen a lot
from the batch and
queue world to the--
EARLL MURMAN: It's OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: --from the batch
and queue world to the lean
world, so any questions
you want to ask her, it's--
EARLL MURMAN: Yeah,
Rose Mary, it's
really critical-- in
transformation to lean,
the people are really,
to me, the key part,
the critical part.
ROSE MARY MUNOZ: Uh-huh.
EARLL MURMAN: And you're
a front-line supervisor,
and you have a value stream.
I guess this is a picture
of your value stream here.
Yours is the gold value stream.
ROSE MARY MUNOZ: Uh-huh.
EARLL MURMAN: So as supervisor,
what are some of the things
that you do when you work
with your value stream team?
ROSE MARY MUNOZ:
The most important
is to work with the
associates because lean
is 90% associates and
10% the rest, material
or maybe supervisor.
They're the most important
ones to introduce lean system,
and they understand
what they're doing.
That's the most
important thing that we
can do to get that [INAUDIBLE].
EARLL MURMAN: Yeah,
Claudio was telling me
that one of the ways
you do this is you
get suggestions from them.
You engage them
with suggestions.
So Rhea here, she's contributed
some kinds of suggestions,
and what happens to
those suggestions
when she contributes them?
ROSE MARY MUNOZ:
The suggestions they
give, we check if--
we try to implement
all the ideas that they have.
When they give me some
idea, we try to implement.
We work with them, and
that way they feel more--
how I can say it?
EARLL MURMAN: More involved?
ROSE MARY MUNOZ: More
involved in helping the team.
EARLL MURMAN: Yeah.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: How do you
help them with the idea?
Do you help them think to it,
or do they come up with idea
by themselves?
ROSE MARY MUNOZ: No, they came
up with the idea by themself.
And when they don't have
no idea, I go with them,
and I would say, for
example, what do you think?
You don't have no idea
how you can get any ideas?
Sometimes, they say, oh, maybe
I don't have too many time
to think and
something like that.
I told her, what
do you think if we
had put, for example, the
[INAUDIBLE] here close to you?
You can save one second.
I said [INAUDIBLE].
That's fine [INAUDIBLE].
We can try it.
They all try anything
that I can help them do.
EARLL MURMAN: So
as a supervisor,
what's the biggest challenge
you have in this job?
I mean, you've got 25 people.
That's a lot right there.
ROSE MARY MUNOZ: Work together.
EARLL MURMAN: Work together.
ROSE MARY MUNOZ: And teamwork,
that's the most important.
When we're all
working like a team,
you can get anything
you want [INAUDIBLE]..
EARLL MURMAN: Well, super.
Well, let's go back
in the factory.
You've got a lot of work to do.
ROSE MARY MUNOZ: Yeah.
Thank you.
EARLL MURMAN: OK, thank you.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Thank you.
So this one's called stitching.
Before in the
computer stitching,
the upper was in the flat form.
Here is the first time
the upper takes a 3D form.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: So it's a cell,
and basically, it will follow--
something stopped here.
You have to understand.
You will follow
these [INAUDIBLE]----
EARLL MURMAN: Yeah.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: --to feed
to what we call the assembly
department.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN:
What is the sole.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Still, in
the stitching department,
you still have continuous flow.
If you looked
between the station
to upper, to upper, to
upper, that associate
just noticed he did not put
another shoe on that tray
until one was removed.
EARLL MURMAN: The combine, OK.
Flow.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Exactly,
so they're pulling--
EARLL MURMAN: Pulling, yeah.
CLAUDIO GELMAN:
--very frequently.
That discipline is
very, very important.
You don't want that
overproduction.
EARLL MURMAN: You're right.
There are two there, two there.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: And
you still have--
they were stopped.
EARLL MURMAN: I
just saw the switch.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Yeah,
and they were stopped.
EARLL MURMAN: As soon
as she pulled one off,
he put one there.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: It takes
months and years to get that,
but they understand.
They understand that the
shoes are not going anywhere
if they overproduce.
EARLL MURMAN: You know,
it looks like a symphony.
Everybody's playing together.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Yeah.
Yes, exactly.
It's a takt.
It's like a rhythm.
The shoe circulates
to the department.
They stopped.
That's why they don't
have a shoe here.
The associate will put a--
and basically, the
department is--
there are two basic operations.
It's called the last
thing, where you--
this is called the last.
EARLL MURMAN: The last, OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: You have a last.
This is a style, and you
have a last per the foot.
The foots are very different.
EARLL MURMAN: Yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Then they have--
the width is David.
That's D. It's called David.
New Balance
specializes in width,
so this particular shoe goes
from B, very narrow, to a 6E,
very wide.
And each foot requires
a different last.
EARLL MURMAN: So how do
we know when the shoes are
going through this cell that--
are they making it for
a particular size last?
CLAUDIO GELMAN: There
is a document that
is printed every
day and distributed
to all the supervisors
per value stream
that they know
exactly the sequence,
so he knows very well.
The flow coordinators
in this teams
knows very well what's coming.
EARLL MURMAN: So that's
done on a daily basis,
so you're really responding
on almost a daily basis
to the pull in customer?
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Right.
Yeah, it's a daily.
Yeah, daily.
Sometimes are weekly.
Sometimes are daily,
but we know exactly.
At the end of the
day or the afternoon
before, it gets put
in these documents.
EARLL MURMAN: Is that
based on the orders that
are coming in for shoes?
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Yeah, it
depends on the work orders.
Some shoes are go
directly to customers.
Some orders go to the warehouse.
It depends who they are for.
It can be a weekly work
order or a daily work order.
Regardless of that,
this document is daily,
and it gets distributed,
again, to the supervisor, flow
coordinator, and set-up people.
Set-up people are the
ones that bring the work.
So there's no question.
So in the case of the
last, the set-up person
will have a document, so
there's no need to talk.
Every single transaction is
very clear who's responsible,
what needs to be done.
EARLL MURMAN: This must
give you a competitive edge
over your competitors
whose shoes are
being made in another country.
And the market is
here, and there's
a time lag between those two.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Yes, it is.
We're working right now with
our lead time of three days.
It's to try to help the
retailers to minimize
the inventory, so
it started Friday.
Saturdays and
Sundays are big days.
On Monday, they place an order.
Three days later, we can
deliver it back to them.
EARLL MURMAN: And this
lady is doing it right now.
She's--
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Absolutely.
EARLL MURMAN:
Real-time response.
OK, cool.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: This is to be
in a customer in three or four
days, and that makes
a big difference.
Basically, in this
department, these associates--
the shoe is put into what's
called a conditioner just
to get some steam to
soften up a little bit.
So when he removes a
last, puts on the paint,
and put the shoe on, it
flexes [INAUDIBLE] to fit.
The shoe gets cemented
on the bottom.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: The sole
is the layer from behind.
The associates with that
yellow machine over there,
basically, what it does
is activates-- maybe
I'll show you a little
more closely here.
So the shoe is cemented.
It's put in this big dryer--
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: --to dry.
The sole underneath,
this comes from behind.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: The right
sole for the right upper.
The cement gets a little
bit of heat in that--
EARLL MURMAN: In that oven?
CLAUDIO GELMAN: It's
called a activator oven.
Then the associate will get the
upper and the sole activated.
They will stick it together,
put it in this big press
where the shoe stays for two
minutes to ensure bonding.
EARLL MURMAN: OK.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: And
then goes to our table
where the packing associates
will do some basic inspections,
will remove any
cement, will apply
the laces, any tags,
advertisements.
Some tissue inside the shoe to
keep its shape inside the box.
EARLL MURMAN: Yeah.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Get packed.
EARLL MURMAN: And that's it.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: And that's it.
EARLL MURMAN: OK, so Claudio,
this now goes to your customer,
and if I--
CLAUDIO GELMAN: Yeah.
EARLL MURMAN: If I go to a New
Balance outlet or a shoe store,
I can buy this.
CLAUDIO GELMAN: You'll see
those shoes, absolutely.
EARLL MURMAN: Claudio,
thanks so much for showing--
CLAUDIO GELMAN: It's
been a pleasure.
Really, a pleasure.
EARLL MURMAN: And you
know, as we're leaving,
I kind of want to know,
what's the next step
in your lean journey?
CLAUDIO GELMAN:
It's interesting.
The answer is more of the
same, but what I mean by that--
everything is
about the thinking.
So what we'll do, we will work
in more sophisticated problems.
We continue sharpening our
problem-solving skills,
so we will be able to resolve
more complicated waste
problems.